cbs news political contributors robbie
mook and terry sullivan join us now
robbie was the presidential campaign
manager for hillary clinton
in 2016 and terry managed senator marco
rubio's campaign good morning gentlemen
robbie let me start with you you went
through this
four years ago with hillary clinton how
does joe biden approach
debating donald trump
yeah well the campaign has announced
that he is going to be laser focused on
his own agenda
you know it's really easy we face this
with hillary it's very easy to get
bogged down and fact
checking uh donald trump a lot of what
he's gonna say is not true
uh trump is is desperate in this debate
to change the narrative somehow let's
stop talking about covet let's stop
making this a referendum on his
presidency
let's bring something else up uh and joe
biden's got to keep this
uh a referendum on donald trump so i
think that's what
uh we'll see him doing but uh he he
cannot get bogged down in checking every
fact otherwise he's never going to talk
about what he wants to say
terry biden got defensive uh in debates
during the primaries at times
is that a danger for him
yeah it really is look as a as a
campaign manager the the one of the
toughest things to do is is to control
what's going to happen in a debate and
and remove as many variables as possible
and uh as robbie said preparing to
debate donald trump
uh is just a bag full of unknowns uh
if this was a fight mike tyson you can
train your your boxer as much as you
want
but mike tyson is i'm sorry donald trump
is the mike tyson
of of uh debaters he's not going to come
in and fight in a normal way that you
can plan for he's going to come in and
bite your ear off
i mean this is this is going to be a
brawl and he's going to be
unconventional and he's just going to
come at you
and that's tough to prepare your
candidate for how do you guys think that
that mr trump is going to handle the tax
story
which has suddenly taken over the
headlines
in 2016. sorry go ahead rob you start
go ahead no i was going to say hillary
faced this
or he faced this from hillary in 2016
too you know she really walked through
this she actually i would argue really
anticipated everything we just saw in
this article
he's just gonna say he was smart um and
frankly
again i i think it's easy to see
something like that as an important
rabbit hole to go down
but the at the end of the day i think
it's a rabbit hole fundamentally the
case joe biden has to make here is trump
lied to the american people
and failed on covet their lives would
have been better if someone else had
been in charge
if he starts getting into taxes um you
know i think it's a diversion from his
his core objectives in this debate for
sure
yeah i completely agree with robbie the
one thing i would add to that is
that if you're going to head down this
line of attack uh
the president is going to see this as
him being smart as him beating the irs
or outsmarting the tax code
if joe biden biden is going to be faced
with this and have to answer it
he needs to attack this as donald
trump's not as successful as he normally
thought he would
donald trump doesn't care if you hate
him what he cares about is if you're
laughing at him and you think he's a
failure
and we saw this anytime that anybody's
gotten the best of him in a debate
it's by minimizing him and laughing at
him and he can't handle that and comes
unraveled and we saw that in
in 2016 on multiple formats that's the
only time you get the best of them so if
so if biden is going to push this issue
he needs to push it as
turns out you didn't make much money
after all you were losing money
well the yeah but no one likes to be no
one likes to hear that either terry
especially if you've been saying
your theme song is money money money no
one wants to hear you don't have any
money money money money or as much as
you said
but listen guys the voting is already
underway the numbers show that more than
one million people have already voted
and if you haven't voted you certainly
have made up your minds is a
belief so how much of a difference do
these debates
make yet i can't wait for tonight i know
many people are very excited to see
what's going to happen tonight but how
much of a difference does it really make
at this stage
i i don't know that it does yeah yeah
and we've seen that the past few
presidential cycles
yeah it just hasn't really made much of
a difference um it's fun
it's fun to watch it's good sport we're
all going to pick winners losers winning
moments losing moments all that
but i don't think it's going to have
much impact on the voters what i would
say is what's the takeaway right if i'm
the biden campaign i want people to come
out of this debate
thinking about donald trump's record if
i'm donald trump i want voters thinking
about
something else about joe biden but
that's really the best the campaign can
do
terry you agree with that you know one
thing that's you know i think
one thing that's been interesting about
this cycle in in 2020
in a year of huge uh instability i mean
we've had
you know riots in the streets we've had
peaceful protests we've had
you know global pandemics we've had
economic collapses
and out of all of those things the one
thing that has been constant is
donald trump and joe biden's polling
numbers it is a
the most bizarre thing i've ever seen
the the national polling league which i
know it's not about national polls but
it's a great barometer
has not changed outside of us a point or
two in either direction
since biden was the functional nominee
of the party terry that's amazing
nothing is going to change this race and
i don't think i don't think the debates
are going to do it
terry the president spent a lot of time
questioning mr biden's mental state
do you think mr biden has something to
prove tonight
yeah i mean the president has made it
really easy for joe biden to pass that
test
um when you spend the past six months to
a year saying someone is sleepy and
on drugs and god knows what else if you
just don't fall off the stage and drool
on yourself you're going to be okay
so the at the end of the day the bar has
been lowered
all right terry sullivan robbie what i
know about it gary putting it in
perspective all right terry and bobby
i'm envisioning drooling now all right
thank you both
our live primetime coverage of the first
presidential debate starts tonight at 9
00 pm eastern
6 pm pacific right here on cbs